une escapade dans le grand nord n'aura
pas permis d'éloigner stephen harper des
questions sur son rôle et celui de son
entourage dans la sphère de filles qu'il
ya de personnes responsables ils sont
les supérieurs sur wright monsieur
d'affilée ils sont en train d'être tenir
responsables pour leur action
exclusivement mike deux filles et son ex
chef de cabinet nigel wright pour le
fiasco pourtant les centaines de
courriels déposé en preuve illustre
l'ampleur des efforts déployés par six
plus importants conseillers pour
camoufler la faire pour le chef du fbi
le leadership mais l'estivé nature il
tant qu'avantage qui sont des mécréants
pourquoi ils les gardent en place il
peut pas d'un côté de la bouche dire
mais ce sont des aliments
et le nom essayé de justifier le fait
qu'ils soient tous encore là le chef
conservateur lui s'en tient à ces lignes
de presse depuis plusieurs jours
que dire du rôle de son secrétaire
principal à l'époque oui novak les
courriels démontre qu'en février 2013 il
est mis au courant du stratagème pour
éviter que de filles ne rembourse les
dépenses contested sa poche 23 mars
nigel wright lui a même écrit j'en
verrai mon chèque lundi comme henri
nowak toutes celles avoir été promu au
poste le plus puissant celui de chef de
cabinet alors qu'il aurait gardé le
silence selon stephen harper ne répond
pas je n'accepte pas cette déclaration
du défunt ils ne répètent surtout pas à
la thèse avancée jeudi selon laquelle et
novak n'ouvrait pas si courriel pour le
parti libéral toutes ces versions sont
invraisemblables ultime en mai sur
harper sera obligé de congédier raynaud
vague parce que toutes les histoires et
toutes les versions
que le gouvernement et monsieur rhin
pour lui même ont offert aux canadiens
ne tiennent pas la route loin de
dissiper la tourmente le témoignage des
deux jours est la relancer et stephen
harper n'a pas fini de voir répondre à
des questions en pleine campagne
électorale car dès la semaine prochaine
son ancien chef de cabinet sera de
retour à la barre des témoins il sera
suivi d'un autre de ses anciens
conseillers et ses manuels à travers ce
radio canada ottawa